[Music]
six years of searching
please let this be it whoa
focus eyes forward took
good boy okay so here's the cinch
this is kumandra each land is named
after a part
of the dragon fang heart
spine tail and talon
we were once unified harmoniously as one
until evil forces were awakened
shattering the peace and dividing the
five lands
mariah this isn't the world i want you
to live in
to restore peace i must find the last
[Music]
dragon
we need you to defeat the evil with the
last of dragon magic
i'm gonna be real with you all right i'm
not like the
the best dragon okay
we need to keep going the world's broken
world warriors assassins
and pickpockets
[Music]
you can't trust anyone maybe it's broken
because you don't trust anyone who
really needs your help
girl ryan and i are gonna fix the world
yes i too wish to join this fellowship
with particularly
[Music]
hold on oh we were doing a jumpy thing
sorry it may
feel impossible but sometimes
you just have to take the first step
i just shave change dragons can do that
look how close my butt is to my head
it's going to make digestion so much
faster
or ordered on disney plus with premiere
access
you